[Music]
welcome to thoughtful Thursday this week
we're going to be discussing how to work
out and how to know for sure that you're
gonna get a true 25 percent ROI deal I'm
here with Paul teller poor you are the
numbers man thank you
unless you think the great thing about
you Paul I wanted to get you on
thoughtful Thursdays because you
yourself are buying properties all the
time they're giving you a true 25
percent ROI yeah but you also are an
anal spreadsheet man you can and you get
the straightedge at people's false
claims where they miss things off so
just talk to me about ROI because 25
percent or that what that means is that
you put 100 grand down and then you get
25 grand a year so after four years
you've made all your money back and
you've got a free house effectively it's
gonna be a cash machine forever Steve
I'm sure it's really good what are some
of the misconceptions and things that
people miss off this spreadsheet love so
it's making it making sure you know all
your numbers
toppdogg every single cost that goes
into that sometimes there's a little
cost in there that can be overlooked so
let's take it from the top of the let's
do it from the person process so okay
deposit rate one knows about deposit
fairly straightforward 25% if you give
your mortgage in there are some deals
around at 20 obviously we can get in a
little bit cheaper as well which is
butter which is great but you need to
speak with a financial adviser around
anything and right now we're talking
about the in a awkward yet because to
work out the ROI you need to know what
am I putting in it which it and what
yeah that's for what is your capital and
your operating expenses yeah she also
will think of it in those are the terms
so obviously capital expense buying a
property you've got your mortgage
application fees some of those allow you
to put it onto the mortgage
make sure you add it to your interest
calculations some people don't
yeah we've got broker fees we've got
solicitor fees you know truth you know
truth you can get it quote quite easily
yeah so a general purchase now around
the thousand to twelve hundred pounds
for a private purchase and it's
interesting as well because a lot of
people safe from and then you just think
you have got that figure in your head
so you're say to your mortgage broker
how much do you charge to give you a
mortgage brought your PHA I
from 300 and then things to a hundred
but then it's action 5/5 day you know
these little things that add up so
solicitors are a great one for that if
it sounds quite expensive to be there
1204 to buy house sir Wow
so you've got the basic conveyancing fee
you've got then various searched are you
a limited company there's extra fees on
that is it an HMO there's extra fees on
that yeah and what area are you buying
what are their search fees yeah okay so
there's enough variables in there okay
it's not all going to the yeah fair
enough it's not just out as well
stamp duty contacts SDLT yeah make sure
that's in there if you're getting the
property from a saucer make sure that's
in there make get those fees in I see a
lot of stuff come through without that I
used to say I was a sorcerer to people
what I was selling the deal to them
because they said I've said the deals
you know really good on top somebody or
anything yeah but your source of feeds a
bit high I need to factor that into my
costs and I was decide this you'd
probably disagree with this I'd say look
look
my saucer fee is not just for you being
able to buy the property because you're
gonna get to see what I've done tap into
my Power Team mm-hmm over the sea look
over my shoulder and see how I bought
this property so it really it's almost
like training yeah but it's still money
coming because my students do it
companies do thrown up alright so you
know doesn't need alaikum o license yeah
can vary area by area you've got a lot
more ties out over a period but some
licenses or three years some of five
years yeah there is my local authority
again furnishing okay making sure you've
got your 13 cost in there as well I
cannot lease that though yeah so we kept
that but fine so you can either put that
in your operating column yeah or you can
have any capital column you choose which
file alive yes cuz if you lease it it's
gonna affect your monthly cash flow
going exactly which actually the quick
the ultimate question is what's gonna
give me more ROI so you can so what I do
my one faulkner spreadsheet is we have
opportunities to either put it
to cost or as an operating castle you're
working out there so we can we didn't
look at the best way of doing yeah so
that so then we've got our monthly or so
so we've done is we've done all right
and so generally what I find I come up
with a number and I call it this is the
cost to get involved in this deal yes
again if you literally sat there with
those words and then you've got your
full amount and and and that might be 20
percent or 25 percent for you deposit it
but then it might be another five
percent it could well be a brawl the
other bits but it's kind of it's gonna
vary from deal to do anybody does HMO
sleeve wallet or whatever and they'll be
horrible to get to a point where you're
committed to buy on a property and
anything crumbs I'm actually in for this
is this and this as well I haven't
thought about although I used to do I
know what you mean and look at it but
then it's good this is a description but
why is it a bit what I'm started out
there'll be a property for 100 grand and
in my mind I'm thinking because that was
that was when you were doing 15 percent
deposits in my mind I'm thinking I need
15 grand yeah now cause there's gonna be
other stuff but I you just think I deal
with that layout you know and I can see
if you too conservative it can put you
off will stop you whereas if you just go
you know what yeah there's gonna be a
few extra costs but I'll just make you
happen even if I need to bang on a
credit card I go overdrawn because I
know that I'm investing here into an
asset that's gonna go up in value it's
gonna give me a monthly profit do you
disagree with that um yes and though
most of the costs are not insurmountable
granted but equally if you were putting
two or three deal together and also near
maxing your credit cards like it's
uncomfortable very quickly for you yeah
so it's just good to know your cash flow
yeah Jesco it's good to end it's better
it's better to be conservative yeah I'm
also not taking action not at all but do
it from a position of knowledge and
power
oh I stand corrected so so that the
worrying thing is now that from from
some of the heights
spreadsheets and numbers is that what
we've just talked about is the easy bit
working out what you need to point is
easy to hold bet is knowing what you're
gonna get on a monthly basis because
that's when you need to start factoring
or fonts and stuff so let's do it's all
we got okay so we've got OCR monthly
interest payment yeah on whatever
financing that's easy easy when I
percent depends on the yeah so without
agency yeah okay
I'm an agent so on this is what people
miss a lot people mix with HMOs it's not
so much the case with single that's but
with HMOs the management company will
say we charged twelve seven I know you
go here but that's not even what plus V
eighty no no no worse than that worse
than that
twelve percent so in your mind you think
all right twelve percent whoever it does
plus V of T not including thirty no
bigger but what they don't factor in is
the fact that tenants in HMOs after six
twelve months often leave yeah and then
you need to paint the heck tumor
management company a tenants finding fit
another another where a tenant finding
fees with HMOs over the years either and
it's something that often people don't
back to at all so I think that's a
really nice a huge one yeah absolutely
right
it's a finest feeder in their 100-150 a
common yeah plus V eighty yeah in you
know organizations it yeah so all right
so we got that so I put ten percent in
for maintenance and voids which covers a
little bit of that yeah but it's if some
it's very hard to to quantify
I'd rather does have a number believe
everything and appreciate there's gonna
be the bit of error at variance around
there is okay so it's but that is a
little bit of a believer you can kind of
adjust is it well I put 10% Mossad yeah
for maintenance and Boyd's yet so guys
we're on the same page yeah then we've
got the biggie gas electric you talking
for heightened as note that well not I'm
talking rising absolutely yeah
absolutely
okay another thing it started as
sometimes people will get confused
because I hear me talk about HMOs a lot
yeah and then they're buying a single
that and they're thinking they need to
budget for gas and this and the other
whereas if it's a family home unless
it's empty
of course if it's empty organized by
even council tax if it's empty you only
to pay yes is that admittedly it's a
reduced council tax but if the house is
empty you can't you're gonna have to be
paint upon the house but if it's tenant
it's a family home all the bills the gas
the electric all that stuff is
completely taken care of but but yeah
gone so it's just bill it's so single
there you're right provision for okay
we'll tax for empty periods which is
gonna be which is any 10% already yeah
also just your building insurance again
is minor yeah forcing all that come on
let's face it there's not that much
money costs no there just isn't that
semester that's just for height to
murder armor for a single layer yeah
you've got your small management fees
which is 10% yeah
the terrace often stay for years and
years most of my single let's some of
them the tenants have been in there
since I bought them 11 years ago and
that's attracted a lot of people and
sometimes you know single let's get
discounted yeah and actually that kind
of long-term view is great a sense on
paper you can think I hate to mow is why
more profitable but in practice that can
not be that dissimilar true yeah okay
what else
so that's thing we let taken care of HM
outside electric and gas yeah so we all
know that the second hottest place next
to the surface of the Sun is in an HMO
bedroom yeah yeah you know what they do
day in the summer have the heat you know
yeah to dry clothes but then they're so
hot they open the windows yeah and let
the heat out mean you thinking my
goodness
so there are mechanisms you can put in
place and still give the tenants control
of the heating but allows you to keep an
eye on where that's going yeah you need
to intervene and have a what do you use
so we use alley Mac I knew that you I
knew that you do that Howard is so cool
it's because you're a control freak
probably all right you know what can't
you say boy I let my tenants do what
they want when it comes to here and
here's my fit I knew that you wouldn't
but my theory is that that and you could
disagree whatever but I know I'm right
because I did a lot but you're awesome
as well listen the heat in even if you
have it on really hard when I got
married right I was living in a big
empty house practically before I got
married sorry and I had practically had
the never he they hate him never on I
didn't cook I used to always he out I
didn't have a TV and and it was just
like pretty much empty then my wife
moves in she's from Africa she likes hot
she wants to get two TVs in the house
she wants to cook all the time in the
kitchen the usual love it and I'm
in geez it's gonna be hard the TV no but
I just decided a little bit what she
wants and the bills didn't talk that
much because I think people think it's
like a mobile phone contract you know
and you go abroad and you get back and
it's just crazy with heating it doesn't
really I can do that it can be fun I
want to come from a position of not
control even though I'm looking trim
throttle come on not control but from
seeing what's going on you'll be one of
those guys sometimes I'm out with a
landlord and they're there on the phone
really smug I'm like what's up and I say
they just turn the heating down in in
hole I'm like nah dude man what is good
and why we like the our system
particularly isn't even look at the
ambient temperature where where the
sensor is you can look at the external
yeah high temperature yeah
so you get a gauge of okay how are these
two things running yeah so sometimes you
know you know we can be saying
Southampton in 25 degrees yes it may be
10 across the north so it's like okay I
wouldn't you know I'd expect that to be
being the case but you can get the data
on it yeah you know what you can just do
the old-fashioned technique that we used
to do where I just asked the maintenance
cars to put matchsticks in the radiator
see so you get only 10 23 control bills
interesting what do you think a wife oh
do you think that because so it really
interesting is Wi-Fi in in HMO
properties I used to say and I still I
still believe this to a point that you
need the fastest Wi-Fi it's really
important you know TV downstairs in the
communal area now I find people sitting
in a bedroom and watch watch their iPad
on 3G we still put the fast as possible
fibre broadband into everything that we
know yeah but people I don't find people
care about the Wi-Fi as much as they did
now that you never use like 4G 5 G's
coming out they do and you know I mean
5g will get you to the same speed as
fibre broadband so it's not it's not
it's not to be a game-changer in my mind
and on my work but then we know when the
broadband goes down
yeah so that's that's that's that's our
major yeah yeah that's really important
I still think the TV's important as well
do you see not my tenants like these
days are interested yeah they even
sit in the communal area anymore no area
is either empty
more yes it's the same tenant that
almost has it has their own lounge and
now I'm doing
he's on buying properties HMOs that have
got slightly bigger bedrooms and I'm not
even looking in the area and if the
bedrooms are a hundred square feet you
don't need to come in there that's very
true
you know and that's any one of our ones
we were acquiring now will be in that
space yeah but I think pivot is a larger
property I think with four bedrooms you
probably get aware that there's a larger
property there is something kind of nice
about coming together again remember
talked about where are you in the market
mmm who are you appealing to yeah so if
it's for professionals working away from
home actually quite nice sit down have a
cup of tea or someone yeah I think I
think that that can work quite well I
wouldn't sacrifice you know too much for
it but I think there's a there's a you
know there's a ranch space mm-hmm so
you've got all these costs worth got
through that electric gas okay I think
got your water bill your council tax
yeah
okay some of the other students you
don't pay counts that's correct
what else we've got we've got insurance
yeah not a lot few Japan yet yeah but
comes in 30 40 quid a month so attacker
now also thing at TV license if you do
have the TV for the 15 quid a month
versus the fine you can get no-brainer
little tip as well is don't put TVs in
the bedrooms because then you're
responsible for separate TV licenses put
one in the main room if they choose to
put a TV in their bedroom then they're
responsible correct yeah in fact just
with property in general if you put
something in then you're responsible
which is why we've I sing all that
properties I like to put as least as
possible in there and if you put a
fridge freezer in there and then it
breaks then you're responsible but if
it's theirs then you know you know it's
less work absolutely
yeah yeah forget all those costs as well
the other thing we always factor in is a
cleaner for the communal areas okay
just just for where we picture each of
those we want to make sure they're
absolutely tip-top but it's really
interesting though is if you show you're
caring for it with us with that small
investment now making more Vanessa they
double their efforts as well so it's all
about
ninety miles half claim to some depends
on the area one of the things I do as
well is if a tenant is trying to hustle
me down on the rent and they're like you
know I've got this lady who's
professional a did you say oh it just
doesn't quite I like it but it's it's
450 I do it from 400 I also look I tell
you what I'll do 45 if you clean all the
communal areas thoroughly once a week so
it's like a bargain evening you know
it's only the gardening or Sato say to
some of the guys if you cut the grass in
the summer using a reason for everything
right always justify if you're gonna
come down the road yeah yeah yeah and
then once you call those diggers yeah
you're gonna then just knock them off
the rent so yeah so we basically then
get to get the rent in we get the
monthly cost down ya know management all
those don't matter and then you go see
what profit you've got correct then the
profit that you've got you're gonna look
at what's the annual profit anything
gonna divide the annual profit by the
total in amount correct and then that's
your ROI is it possible with all those
conservative things in place to still
get comfortable health a twenty five
percent return on investment we don't
touch anything below you don't touch
anything below it now so top tips on how
to find these properties and how to do
that well that comes down to having a
really great network so there's an old
adage which is you make your money when
you buy mmm so getting the right
properties at the right price from day
one it's about a little bit of control
without managing those cuts because if
you let the heating go wild at gas cost
that you put at sixty quid can be 120
hundred and fifty quid a month quite
quickly so if you're not careful
particularly with older properties that
can get away from you quite quickly yeah
yeah all right so that's great Paul
you've been awesome come you know under
the dough I've never done this before
but I'm gonna put a link beneath with a
basic spreadsheet to how people can work
out the ROI like an ROI spreadsheets
yeah if you want the HMO one folks you
need to come to the crash course and
request that but for a basic spreadsheet
I'm going to put one below and you can
just click it download it for free so
awesome Paul thank you so much
shaaka hope you guys enjoyed that it is
super important to work out your figures
properly however when you know what
you're doing there's no reason why you
can't find properties that given you a
ridiculously high return on investment
and more importantly by them below
market value as well so it's good it's
gonna mean that you've made money equity
straightway hope to see the property
investors crash course I'll see you next
week thank you so much
you